welcome welcome welcome in to another
edition of Market takes we're looking
out at all the things that you need to
be looking out for this week all the big
things coming up and it's not just
economic data this week we've got a
couple big things coming up this week
that you're going to want to look out
for that aren't just releases from the
government or statistical agencies first
of all starting at 3 A.M Tuesday morning
that is tomorrow you've got the start of
Amazon Prime day I'm going to tell you
why you're going to want to look out for
Amazon Prime day and why that could move
markets and why that will be important
for the economy in just a minute also of
course it is CPI week we got the
Consumer Price Index coming out on
Wednesday morning we'll be right here on
Market takes breaking all that down and
then on Friday we have the start of
earnings season The Unofficial start of
big earnings season with those big Banks
you've got Citigroup JP Morgan Wells
Fargo all coming out on Friday we're
going to dive into why that'll be
important for this week so first things
first let's start with with Amazon Prime
day that kicks off tomorrow morning 3
A.M it's going to be July 11th and 12th
what it is Amazon Prime day is just a
big day where Amazon offers a lot of big
discounts for its Prime members they pay
about 15 a month and if you are a member
of the you know the prime group if you
subscribe to Amazon Prime you get big
discounts on Amazon
um really a lot of tech items a lot of
things that have really you know been
marked down significantly and that's
designed to bump up those sales this has
been a really big event I don't want to
say a big day because over the past few
years Amazon has stretched Prime day
into a couple days as they'll be doing
this year but over 10 billion dollars in
sales so say uh you know consumer
reports about Amazon Prime day over the
last couple times now we've got this
year coming up a lot of other retailers
have actually joined into this and so
this has become not just the thing about
Amazon but you've got Target launching
Target Circle members having their
target Circle day uh that was starting
July 9th you've also had in previous
years Walmart has joined in with their
Walmart plus program so you've got some
of the biggest retailers all across the
board joining in on this big sales day
and this makes this not just about
Amazon but about consumer sales about
online retail sales about the pickup or
an attempt to really jump start and jolt
hire some of those sales that have been
consistently kind of lower in the summer
months so this started back in 2015 and
historically had been the week after
July 4th but in 2020 uh Prime day was
moved to October in 2021 it was also in
June and October now it's back to being
in July and we are going to see just how
much timing matters and how much this
can really jolt up those retail sales of
goods which have been lagging want to
put something up here on your screen
right now and that is just the chart of
U.S retail sales this is the change that
we have seen year over year going back
now if you look in 2023 the start of
2023 in January and then coming into
what we're seeing last month you have
just seen a pretty consistent decline in
terms of the overall percentage change
in retail sales those sales have been
coming down pretty consistently going
back all the way to about mid 2022. now
we have seen inflation has come down as
well but we know really big price
increases were jolting those numbers
higher and now we have seen a declining
number especially when you break out the
good side of those retail sales numbers
those numbers have been coming down and
that chart really just illustrating the
Slowdown that we have seen in retail
sales and that's why Amazon Prime day
coming up here in July could be a big
deal again you've also got Target
participating you'll likely have Walmart
participating and we know consumers have
been spending a lot more on Services
going out to bars restaurants Barbers
things like that rather than Goods
things that they purchase on Amazon.com
or Walmart or any of those so this will
be a good test of the economy is the
good sector can the good sector really
pick up and repeat some of those big
numbers that we had seen for Amazon
Prime day in the past now what we also
know about consumers consumers have been
loading up credit cards they haven't
really been buying with cash or buying
with debit cards using that money
straight from their account they've been
borrowing money essentially taking out
those personal loans consumer credit
card debt is at a record high and we
also see that while consumer credit card
rates are at record high so we know
folks are paying a lot more to borrow
that money from the banks in the form of
credit cards will that continue and will
they keep doing that to splurge on
something like Prime day you know this
isn't the thing where we've seen
consumers really switching more to
Necessities more to things like
groceries more to things like gas and
then spending their money there rather
than on those big purchases from Amazon
and other retailers are they going to
continue to do that for something like
sales with Amazon and and we'll see if
that continues so another big test of
the economy can this trend we've seen of
folks loading up those credit cards and
spending that money continue for
something you know it's not really about
needs this is more about wants about
tech items about VR headsets and things
like that speakers and all those kind of
smart devices will that motivate folks
to keep spending this could also be a
really interesting test for the health
of the economy we will see that Consumer
Credit Data that's out today at three
o'clock but it is for May so it's a
couple months delayed but that is going
to be a good test for the overall health
of the economy do consumers keep
spending as they have we have seen
retail sales as we just showed you on
the screen come down for a bit one
caveat to this Amazon Prime day because
again this could move stocks uh this you
know if it breaks the set the pattern
that we have seen of lower retail sales
of lower good sales that could really
push stocks higher if the numbers are
disappointing that could move stocks
lower and this could be something that
moves the market so you're going to want
to look out for that one caveat like I
said is that there isn't really an
official metric Amazon doesn't put out
their numbers last year for example
rather than disclose the total number of
sales they said Amazon Prime members
saved 1.7 billion dollars more than any
other Prime day well that doesn't tell
us how much they spent right it doesn't
tell us how much actual Revenue was
drawn doesn't tell us how much profit
was made it just kind of tells us okay
well they saved a lot of money great
um independent analysts though like
digital Commerce 360 and Adobe they
provide some estimates and some info and
some Intel so we can get an idea for
what happened so you want to look out
for those reports and those could move
markets second thing we want to talk
about this week is CPI inflation data I
want to throw up here on your screen
just the trend that we have seen from
CPI now what you see there is a
consistent decline in the in in the
year-over-year inflation rate we've seen
11 straight months of declining CPI of
declining inflation and that is
definitely what the FED wants to see so
that chart up there on your screen
illustrating the trend that we have seen
for a while going back about a year in
CPI and you know we have seen just a
decline in inflation that's a good thing
you know those prices have been coming
down since the FED has been acting now
the big question is could we see CPI
rise again and the answer is yes however
economists are expecting a very bullish
reading for June economists see expect
to see if inflation declined to 3.1
percent on the CPI now that would be
huge because it would bring CPI down
much closer to the fed's target range a
lot of folks think that you know the FED
would actually be okay with three
percent inflation a lot of folks think
the FedEx should actually be targeting
three percent inflation so if we get
that three percent number that would be
really big and that would be important
now here's why that could we could see
an increase in CPI we have seen Services
spending continuing to rise uh even
coming into this last month the last few
months we've seen Services spending pick
up core CPI has not been declining as it
had been previously we've also seen
housing prices pick up significantly
lately and that's the biggest component
of CPI of course the fed's favorite
metrics CPI declined in June but did
pick up in May so we could see that kind
of transfer into or translate into what
we see on the CPI report now the CPI
report could move the market in a number
of ways even though if we get that three
percent number that would be bullish
overall for the market could see stocks
really take off but that could push bond
yields up higher as folks sell out of
those bonds and say hey the stock
market's going to start taking off I
don't want to own bonds anymore I want
to own stocks so I can make a lot more
money well that could push bond yields
up because as we know when folks sell
bonds the prices decline the rates the
yields rise and that could again make
those more attractive and kind of create
this inverse correlation between stocks
and bonds and you could actually say
that hurt the stock market so a lot of
interesting things to break down on CPI
we will be right here on Market takes
breaking that down for you on Wednesday
last thing we want to talk about for
this week is those Bank earnings that we
got out on Friday I want to throw us
right here up on your screen to just
show you how the stock market has been
performing as you see that light blue
line up there that's the NASDAQ the dark
blue line that's the S P 500 overall the
market so far this year really since
March has been kicked into high gear but
those Bank stocks you see the green line
the white line the red line there on
your screen have really underperformed
and that just illustrates that bank
stocks even the big ones even though
they weren't the ones affected by what
happened with those Regional Banks they
have really continued to underperform
now if we get another big blowout
earnings release from the second quarter
earnings reports that we see on Friday
this could move the market significantly
because Bank stocks have really been one
of the big underperformers for the
market if on the other hand Bank
earnings disappoint which folks aren't
really expecting right now they expect
the banks to do pretty well but that
could pull the market back down kind of
snap us maybe out of this high that
we've been on where the NASDAQ up 30
percent so far a year to date the S P
500 up more than 12 percent up around
that 13 number that could snap us out
here's what to look for with JPMorgan
Chase that is the biggest bank in the
U.S more than 60 million customers it's
going to tell us a lot about the US
consumer how much are consumers spending
on debit versus credit cards are we
still seeing a big pickup in credit card
borrowing are they spending more on
debit how did JPMorgan do after the
ridiculous earnings score they had in q1
20 12.6 billion in profits 38.3 billion
in Revenue are they able to replicate
that keep that party going or did things
pull back in the second quarter with
City how much loan loss Provisions did
they put away are banks really convinced
that this soft Landing can happen or are
they worried are they saying we got to
put some money away because we're
worried that people aren't going to be
paying back those loans they've taken
out from us and is deal making back we
have seen a lot of the data saying no
it's not banks are hurting a little bit
so we'll see how City responds to that
Wells Fargo they also had a big first
quarter increased profit by 30 percent
increased net interest income by around
45 percent are they able to replicate
that analysts are expecting some big
numbers from the stock market and we're
going to see if that can continue so
we're going to get out of here but again
what to watch out this what to watch out
for this week Amazon Prime day over the
next couple days CPI on Wednesday will
be right here on Market takes 10 a.m
eastern time you'll hope you'll join us
in those big Bank earnings on Friday and
listen that's going to do it for us here
on Market takes I am Dion rabone
reporter at the Wall Street Journal we
will be here Wednesday morning morning
10 a.m on doing Market takes hope you'll
be with us and join us when we do it
next time
cool